This is my official. I'm in the home of Jean Starker Roth and today is November 13th, 2007.
Today Jean and I are going to be talking about some of the community activities that she's been involved with.
And I'd like to ask her some questions as well on a more philosophical side of things asking her to reflect a little bit about her life and some of the things that she's accomplished.
So when we left off last time, you had just told me about permit permits passing.
At that time, you were your children were grown.
Almost everybody was out of the house and in college.
And that's where it came.
Can't wait till here.
She was in the sorority house. She was the same.
And then when her dad died, by then she moved home to be with me.
And she was engaged and to be married in June of that year.
He died in February.
And so she said she'd come home and stay with me.
And so I got to know my future son-in-law quite well during that period.
But it was a very tough time to be enthusiastic about a wedding.
And you know, I knew her wasn't going to be with us.
Anyway, that was where that stood, I guess.
Did you have other friends in that sort of thing at that era who were really comfort to you, sort of took you through that difficult?
No, not really.
Well, it shouldn't say that.
There were a couple of couples that really stood by me.
But it's amazing.
In that era, and I think it's true today when you are no longer a couple, it's a different story.
Different social scenes.
And I had one lady's tell me very bluntly, she said,
Well, I won't be inviting you to dinners anymore.
It makes an uneven number.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And so, you know, people see things differently.
But a mighty hell of sage to him, howl.
She was a she and Jim were wonderful support.
And now I'm kind of supporting them because Jim has a disease that we will not get well from.
And so, I try to take her out to lunch and do things with her now.
So, you know, it all comes full circle.
Yes, it does.
Yeah, that's an interesting statement to, because I think that has probably changed.
In this generation, I don't think there is that same sense that you only socialize with couples.
There's lots of relationships among women.
Yes, that's right.
Good.
When there was at that time.
And you probably built those kind of relationships gradually as you.
Yes.
And you know, the thing of it is that.
I think that people don't realize when you're in your 50s.
What it's going to be like when you're alone when you're in your 80s.
And people are much more aware of that I think now when they used to be.
People were more self-centered I think.
And then the other thing that I think about my life is that when I did everything together,
we weren't big on going places with other couples.
We went with our family.
We went fishing.
We went hunting with the boys.
And I did my little things with the hospital and that sort of thing.
But basically we did our social things just together.
Yes.
Uh-huh.
So you had a really special bond and that's hard to recreate.
That's right.
More substituted.
So what kind of things did you do in that time to kind of move through the morning stage?
Well, I plan the wedding.
And that was a full time job.
I can imagine.
And of course when a person dies, they're so much to take care of.
And as I've mentioned before, I had very little money that was coming in routinely.
And I had to figure out how I was going to support myself and whether I had to go back
to work or what I was going to do.
Because we had a lot of assets, but we didn't have any cash flow.
And so I hired a man to manage my first lands that were left over from the mail.
And as I've said before, I trusted him implicitly.
But I really didn't feel like I had a handle on it.
Because I didn't know anything about Timberland and managing it.
And so he did a lot of work on how I don't know what they call that.
He drew pictures of the forest and then where we should log and where we should do with different sections of it.
And we should have put that better.
But anyway, that went on for a couple of years.
And when I needed some money, I'd say, you know, got a log.
But then I decided that after I got my wits about me and got kind of settled down, I thought,
well, you know, I know a lot about real estate and how that works.
So I think I'll do a 1031 just like my father did.
And so I sold off the timber manager surveyed the timber land that I wanted to sell first.
And to see how much I could get from that.
And so then I found a building that I could buy.
And so we changed those two.
And that worked out so well that I did it for more times.
Because that gave you at least a regular source of rent.
Because I had the money coming in from the rents from the real estate.
And then I knew how much I had to spend.
So anyway, that worked out very well.
And it's still to this day.
I own those properties.
He said the biomarker property was one of those things.
Well, the biomarker was a little different.
Because I hadn't heard of that from my mother's estate.
And so that was a little bit different.
But it also had a 30 year lease on it.
Which was just peanuts.
You know, because it was so such an old easy.
Why my father did that?
I do not know.
But anyway, there wasn't much income from that.
I see.
Not like it is today.
Yeah.
Is that still your property today?
Yes.
I own that corner there.
Ninth and circle.
It's been very.
Now that I have a decent lease.
So it gives me some income.
That's good.
So you got involved in your real estate business.
And was that the time that you sort of started getting involved in community activity?
Yes.
And we, I had always been interested in the hospital.
Because my dad had always, he was one of the movers and shakers when the hospital was in bankruptcy
down here on the Harrison Street.
And he and a group of other men pulled that hospital out of the,
got it going again.
And then my husband was interested in the hospital and served on the board of the hospital
when they moved from Harrison out to the hill.
And so I was always involved in the auxiliary.
And my mother and Mrs. Ed Woodcock were the two ladies who started, they held a tea and asked women
to come.
And that's how the auxiliary started the present hospital.
That's interesting.
So that we were always involved as a family, more or less, in the hospital.
And of course I'm a wind permit, they made me an honorary trustee of the justee board.
And so I've been very active in that and helped raise money for the various projects
that they've had, like the Pastaiga house.
I was co-chair with the heart center with Mario Pastaiga.
And then I also supported him when he wanted to do his house.
They call it the house.
Yeah.
And so he and I worked together real closely on that.
It's fundraising for the most part.
Yes.
And were you also involved in a cancer center there at the hospital?
And the hallway out in that building is named for Kermit.
Mm-hmm.
Was that his project as well?
No, you didn't.
No, I'm really, I think that was pretty much my project.
But it was one of the first fundraising projects that I had.
Because I knew a lot of people in town, you know.
And I kind of knew who to ask.
Yeah.
That's what's important.
You have a long list of things that you've been involved with here.
And I could ask you about each one of them.
But you could also just tell me to direct me a little bit.
Which ones you feel are your major points of pride?
Well, of course the park is very much.
And that was an interesting how that came about.
I killed her built this house.
And when we were through building it, he came to me and asked me if I would loan him some money
to own the corner where the park is.
Mm-hmm.
And he asked, he had plans drawn up.
And he was going to build a big high rise, something a rather there of office buildings.
And I said, no, I said, I don't think that's what ought to be on that corner.
And I said, the chamber is next door.
You're going to hide the chamber of commerce building.
Mm-hmm.
And as people come over the bridge, they will not see where the chamber is.
And I said, I don't think that that ought to be built on that corner.
Well, he picked up on that.
Mm-hmm.
And within, I think it was just two or three weeks.
It was a very short period of time.
There was a consensus between the university, the city, and the chamber.
And they all pitched in and bought that property from Ike.
Mm-hmm.
And then they came to me and asked if I would land escape it.
Oh.
And so that's how permit's name is on that part.
I see.
Mm-hmm.
So that all worked out just fine.
Everybody was happy.
And I still look after it.
And I get after them when they don't keep the park up.
Because I have also donated funds to the then county foundation for the purpose of keeping that park up.
Mm-hmm.
And they're supposed to use it for the, you know, to put in some perennials.
And sort of thing.
And now I'm after the chamber because their trees have grown up so much that you can't see their building.
Mm-hmm.
And I think they ought to take those trees down.
And so that when people come over the bridge, they can see where the chamber is.
That's true.
Yeah.
So anyway, I'm working on that.
It's good.
I've never stopped that kind of thing.
Keep them.
Keep them spiced up there.
Now let's see.
The other thing I think is that I belong to the homeck.
And that was started.
My interest in that was a long, long, long ago.
And that was an idea.
It was the lady in charge of the homeck part of the state extension service.
And she and I had known each other because, of course, I'd grown up in Kervales, and they live not far from us.
Well, when I was teaching school up from McKenzie, but she called me one day.
Did was that in Wades thing?
Well, about taking the job with in class up at it.
No.
This is different.
Okay.
So I was up the McKenzie teaching and that summer before the summer was out.
She called me one to know if I wanted to job in Lane County doing work with people who wanted to process their produce.
Either canning or freezing or whatever.
And I said, oh, I'd love a job for the summer.
So she said, well, fine.
So then about halfway through the summer, why she called me.
And she said, we have an opening in an estoria for a war food assistant.
And this is during the war.
Yes, you did tell me about that.
Well, then I won't repeat that.
Okay.
And so that's how I got into the extension service because then the war food assistant was then.
The class of county liked what we did up there with the women.
And so they asked, they, they, you see extension services is funded by federal state and county funds.
And so the county was going to go ahead and do their part to fund the extension service and that county was still going.
But I started that whole program up there.
So that was part of the state.
Home economic system.
Yes.
Uh-huh.
And then you became a rusty on that.
What they called a home demonstration.
A demonstration.
Otherwise known as a home demon.
Hahaha.
That's kind of a positive and a negative.
Yeah, right.
I guess you can see.
Huh.
And then eventually became the chair of the College of Home Economic Development Council.
Yes.
That was the stuff that you took.
Yes, that was when a Kinsey Green was Dean.
And I was chairman of the Advisory Committee for probably six or seven years.
And then when the Tammy Brave became the Dean, why she asked me to continue.
However, we don't have a chairman.
I don't think as such.
We just have a advisory committee.
I see.
And one of the some of the projects that you did through that group.
And you're well.
We raised money too for the college.
And we talk about where the college is going.
What needs to be done.
What needs to be processed in the way of whatever we think that people ought to be thinking about.
You know, they come when Tammy Brave took over that Dean's ship.
It was combined with the College of Physical Education, I think it was.
And then they called it Health and Human Science.
And so she came to me and wanted to know about the history of home economic side of that.
And she had the other group.
And we formed them together.
So now we do both.
I see.
And is that the group that started the Bates Family Study Center?
Yes.
And I was on that committee to help with that.
What is the purpose of that study center?
It's mostly studies of either children, development, which is the, the have a.
Arts degree, nursery school there.
And also gerontology.
And so, but it's expanded a lot since we started.
I think there's lots of research goes on on there.
I don't know, I think the bone density project is probably in the basement of the women's building.
I don't think it's over at the Bates Center.
But it's all intertwined.
Although that research.
So the Bates Center is an actual building.
Yes.
And I was on the committee that helped fund that.
We raised quite a bit of money for that.
Among them was the lady who was.
The original Betty Crocker.
And she was a graduate of Oregon State.
I didn't realize that.
Yes.
And so, I'm trying to figure it out.
Anyway, she didn't.
She came out here from and worked with us to get this, to get it going.
And took a big interest in it.
And of course, left us the big sum of money that the major donor of that building.
Because it's named after her.
Well, she didn't like much staying downtown at the hotel.
So she used to come and stay with me.
Oh.
So I enjoy being with her because we had an awfully good time when she stayed with me.
And then I would take her, you know, around where she wanted to go.
That time I drove a lot better than I drive now.
And so I provided transportation for her.
More fun.
So she, was she older than you?
Oh, yes.
She's been gone many years now.
She began to go downhill.
During the time that she gave the money to the family study center.
And then the last time she came out, she really wasn't herself.
She came with a gentleman who was her.
I don't know what you call him.
I'm a kind of a consultant for their money.
And he took kind of took over caring for her too.
But she stayed with me and he stayed downtown.
That's fun.
So I offered these baits.
These baits.
I have to hear that mean.
Yeah.
It's an awful way for people like that, isn't it?
I just did it earlier today, though.
So you were also involved in the 4-H foundation at the state level.
Yeah, because my head, I think we talked about that.
When I was growing up, I had the daughter of the head of the state.
Harry Seymour was head of the state.
And I had her, his daughter for my 4-H teacher.
Our leader, I guess you'd say.
And so I was always active in 4-H.
When my children came along, they were active in 4-H.
Both of the girls had, they were state winners in their address competition.
They took, I taught them some, but they had a great leader.
Mrs. Wells was her name.
They lived out on the corner of Walnut.
And 20.
Walnut.
Where's the stop sign at Walnut before you go up the hill?
Yeah, there's the stop late at 27th and then at 29th.
Well, I think it's the one at 29th.
Because that's the one where you go out 29th and go up and around the hill and then down.
Well, she ended that corner and why she was a great leader.
She knew a lot about sewing and I thought it was better for the girls to get it from somebody else.
So they went out there and sewed a lot for her.
And then my dad was one of the movers and shakers along with Bergen.
The guy that was head of the state 4-H was his name.
Well, I have to look that up.
Okay, I don't remember what it meant.
Bergen sticks in mine.
Bergen, Bergen Hutton?
I think that was the name.
I can check on that too.
Yeah, put a question.
Okay, that because I don't know for sure.
Anyway, Bergen Hutton, okay, well, just say that's who it is.
Came to my dad and he wanted to buy this property over in Salem that was for sale and it was Timbernan.
And so my dad went over there and the idea was to build a camp for 4-Hers.
Well, it was a pretty big project.
And my dad was very involved in that.
And so then when it came along, I was a treasure, I think, you know.
I don't know, I was some officer in the 4-H program that was established to run that.
To run that camp at the state level.
Yes.
And eventually we had to sell off half of the timberland, which just killed me because it was should have been self-sustaining.
But, you know, people don't realize that timber is a renewable resource.
And you just harvested every 40 years instead of every year, like a lot of crops.
Yeah.
And so we could have, if we've been able to save that land, we could have had it rotating.
So that we could have always had some income, didn't work out.
But they did save half of it.
And now we've got a really wonderful fundraiser, Randy is his name.
What he's last name is, but he's great.
And he is running the camp and they're just, and they're getting them.
What do you call it?
I want to say they're applying for fundraising.
For grants?
Yes, yes.
And now they're just doing really well.
And they're able to keep it up and it looks great.
And so I was involved in that as being on the 4-H board.
And so I became very interested in that because I wanted to see it go.
Sure.
Yeah.
And my dad provided money for the swimming pool of that camp.
And then Kermit and I gave some money for the upkeep of it.
It seems like in general, you had a few that swimming related.
Yes.
That you gave.
Was there a special reason that you were interested?
We were always thought that swimming was very important for Oregonians because we have so
much water.
And when we would see people drown because they couldn't swim, we thought that was just
terrible.
And so we've always supported water-related activities.
And we, and I still do that because I support through the Bend County Foundation.
I support over instance, lifts for people to get in and out of pools.
So they can swim.
And then I think we already talked about the girls going to camp.
Yes.
And they didn't want to go back because it wasn't a swim.
So Kermit and I talked it over and we'd make some money in the stock market.
And so we decided we'd give stock to them.
And so they built their swimming pool.
But we wouldn't let anybody know that we'd done that because we didn't want the kids to
go to camp and everybody's saying, they gave to the swimming pool.
And so it's never been named or anything.
But we didn't want the kids to know.
So did your family always have a swimming pool?
Yes.
I think your kids were growing up.
At least when Kermit and I, we always had a swimming pool.
Of course my dad didn't because he supported the 4-H1, but he didn't support family.
But we did have a pond out in the woods that we could use in the summer time.
But Kermit was, I think, did I tell you about him building that swimming pool?
No.
Well, when we built our house over on Jackson Street, we didn't have a swimming pool.
And so he came home one day and he said, well, what would you think?
If we built a swimming pool across on the property across the way that we owned.
And he said, I could bring in 12-12 timbers and put them together in the corners.
And then we could put your paper down for the paint job.
And then put plastic around it.
And it would be 4 feet deep.
And I said, well, I think that would be great because the kids were little.
And they could have a lot of fun and it was just like a big pool pool.
So we did that.
And I think that lasted for probably five or six years.
Every year we tear it down and re-put your paper and plastic.
And it would last the summer.
And then we decided we built a swimming pool.
So we did that.
But it wasn't covered.
And so that wasn't very satisfactory in Oregon.
So when he closed the mail, he came to me and he said, I've got to take the metal off the roof of some of the machinery that are in the mail.
And he said, if we cleaned it up and cut off the end or the logs of hit it, he said, I could bring that metal in.
And we could have a building over the pool.
And I said, no, thank you.
I don't want a metal building in my yard.
And he said, well, now just wait a minute.
How tell you about how we're going to do this?
It's better than you think.
So anyway, the back part of it was all metal.
And then we put boards that was a very nice awning over the front of it.
But then was all wood.
And then we had sliding glass doors.
And from the street, you couldn't tell what it was.
It's still there.
And covered over the whole pool.
It's interesting.
And we built a sink and a bathroom out there.
And a blazing girl's breast dressing rooms.
Wow.
And it was really a nice little.
And of course, we entertained all the kids.
And on the camp, our girls, the blazing house.
Our kids whoever came around.
This was wonderful because the kids were at our house.
And we knew what they were doing.
And so it was just a wonderful pool.
And the kids all the time they were growing up.
That's great.
And so that's still a use over there.
Oh yeah.
So that's good.
Well, that sort of leads me to my, I wanted to ask a little bit about
Kermit's community involvement.
Because I know it sounds like he was also involved in the scouts to a certain event.
Yes.
Yes, it was with the scouts in Eugene.
I don't know what level of scouting that was.
Whatever it was.
He used to go to Eugene to meetings with boy scouts.
And it was very active.
And he did a lot of fundraising for the boy scouts.
And he always said that he didn't like to ask people from money.
But because of his relationship with the mill, there were lots of times when he had
partial lots of something that he couldn't really sell.
But they were very usable.
So he would donate those.
He liked in kind giving.
And he got confused for the boy scouts.
And he would ask various people who manufactured things.
If he thought the scouts could use it like then he and that burned very well.
And in fact, I still do that a lot with my fundraising.
We try to get in time to gifts.
Interesting.
Because people don't mind giving things that they've manufactured.
And those canoes were perfectly good.
But maybe they had a chip out of the paint or something.
They couldn't sell them.
But they were perfectly usable.
Interesting.
Yeah.
That's a great service to provide.
Yes.
It's a rope or those heels on it.
Giving was his thing.
Interesting.
He was also involved with the rotary and other groups around town.
Yes.
He was a Rotarian.
And after he died, I made him a fellow when the rotary club.
He was really fond of the rotary group.
Were there some things that he was particularly involved with things that were close to him?
I don't remember that he was in particularly involved with rotary.
But he may have been more than I realized I don't know.
Yeah.
But he was involved in the church.
He was a justi of the church.
Yeah.
He did that.
And he wasn't a joiner.
Really.
He didn't like to join.
Very much really.
So he did his work on the outskirts.
Yes.
That works that well.
Another thing I have on list of your credits is the E.E. Wilson Foundation.
What's been your involvement there?
Well, I was on that for a number of years.
And the Fred Zoolawon was head of that.
And managed it from the very beginning when E.E. Wilson died.
And I knew E.E. Wilson.
And so I guess they thought that I would be interested in managing what he had given to the college.
And what really wasn't to the college.
It was just, I think it was kind of just given.
But he had to have a board managing it.
And Pete Smith lived next door to us over on Jackson.
And he was on the board.
And so then he got me involved.
And I was on that for a number of years.
Is that managing the lens?
No, the money that was in the bank that was accumulating interest and so forth.
And the duty of the board was to have kids apply for that for money from that.
And then we had to read their applications and decide who was going to get what?
So scholarships.
Yes.
For OSU?
Well, it could be.
As I remember it, it could be any kind of forgotten.
I think it's any Oregon school.
And that scholarship is still available.
Yes, it is.
And present value.
Yes.
And it seems to me like it has to be Benton County youth.
I could be.
I think it is.
Well, that was a long time ago when I served on that.
I see you haven't done that for a while.
No.
So most recently, the things that you're still involved in.
Are you still involved in forage?
Or the economic sit-up?
No.
I'm still, I serve on the advisory committee for the home and the library.
And the hospital is an honorary trustee and the museum of Benton County Museum.
That's a lot of responsibilities.
Well, I've quit just recently.
I've quit the museum and I've quit the library.
So I'm down to the hospital and the health and human science.
And you've quit them just to give yourself a little more free time?
Yes.
It's just too much.
It is.
But it's an incredible gift to the community.
Do you think that as you were talking about how, you know, you had a good year in the
future?
Do you think that's still going on at that same level in the stay and age?
That's the same sense of philanthropy that people of your era had?
No.
I don't think so.
I think everything now is based on what I can do to get rid of the money for tax purposes.
I really think that people give to get their tax off.
And of course, I've always believed that I would like to give money to something where
I know it's going then to taxes.
So I try to give as much as I can and not have to pay tax on it.
Yeah.
But it seems like your choice of beneficiaries has a lot to do with your personal interests.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
It's your own home.
Yes.
Your personal involved not only in terms of giving money, but also in giving a expertise
at advice.
Yeah.
Because I want to know what they're doing with the money.
I think that makes you different than some other donors too in some ways.
Oh, probably a lot of people give money.
And then they've done, you know, they don't pay attention.
But I really like to know what they're doing with it.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
The one big organization that you've given to is OSU.
We haven't talked about that at all.
I'd love to hear more about your involvement there and all the things that you've contributed
I know a lot of it has been real fundraising for various real estate ventures.
Uh-huh.
Isn't that true?
Well, I think that when you know a lot of all of this stuff that goes on is who you know.
Mm-hmm.
And I'm really proud of the fact that there were three ships available are fishing vessels.
I should say, available in Newport.
And I had become very friendly with Bruce made in his life, Mary-Doo.
And his mother, because they wanted me to go on a trip.
And his mother needed a roommate.
So I said, well, I would go and room with her.
Well, we just got along fine and we just became really good friends over Newport.
So anyway, the more I heard about what Bruce made was doing.
I was very impressed with what he does and his science that he's promoted with whales.
So anyway, there were some, when the fishing industry over there went kind of went
to compute by there were three men who wanted to donate their boats to as you for research.
Mm-hmm.
Well, the trustees, who were the people who say yes or no, there's a little, you know, bored.
They didn't know what did they do about Bruce made, never heard of him, didn't know anything about him.
Well, I had followed him because he's on BBC and he's on history channels and all of those things.
And he was doing great things about tagging whales so that they knew where they were going and what they were doing.
And so John Irving was one of the men who was trying to get the board, the Moes U board, to accept these ships because he thought it was a great thing for them to be able to re-retrofit them and get them fixed for research.
Well, so far, they've only done one, but they're available, but anyway, backing up, he called me one day and he said,
would I be willing to speak to the trustees about Bruce made?
And I said, oh, I'd love to because I really think he does a good job.
So anyway, I told him, I said, how many of you know Bruce the name Bruce made?
So I proceeded to tell him who he was and what he'd done and what a wonderful research he was doing.
So then they were all skitteries about insurance on these boats.
But they finally worked it out with, I don't know who, but anyway, they accepted the three boats and I'm really proud of the fact that I kind of encouraged him to do this.
Absolutely, yeah, but you know sometimes it's just who you know.
That's right, and having that personal touch.
Oh, I'm willing to be there and say, yeah, I know of this man and I can speak for him.
That's right.
And I can tell him a little bit about what he does.
His mother, I don't know whether you want to put anything about this in, but I think she's such a dear woman.
She's just a little short thing. She's probably not five feet tall.
She studied under Frank Lloyd Wright in some registered architect.
She studied a library of science and as a degree in whatever library is.
And she's this one smart lady.
She's just there and has a wonderful sense of humor.
Just enjoyed her knowing.
Oh, that's great.
Unfortunately, now she's in a rest home in Newport.
Doesn't have her mind very clear right now.
She's getting older.
Some of the rest of it.
So you've done some work as a lot of work through the foundation as well through the OSU foundation.
Well, I'm on the OSU foundation.
I wouldn't say I do much work.
But I go.
I see.
So that's more of being a member of the board and not necessarily anything.
Yeah.
Things that you're most proud of.
No.
In fact, I'm not very proud of what they're doing right now.
We won't put that in.
We won't, okay.
All right.
You say so.
Are there things that OSU that you look at and think?
I'm so pleased to be on the both that you, that you got for Bruce's project.
But are there other things there that you look at and think?
I'm so glad to have been a contributor to this.
Well, a library, of course.
I think our library is just one of the nicest ones in the Northwest.
It's amazing.
And I'm very supportive of Carol Butcher.
I think she does some very innovative things.
The most recent one that she's done is having that baby sitting.
She has an area that she has and the students can come and bring.
If they're studying in the library, they have to stay in the library.
But if they're studying, they can bring their children.
And let them off at this little care center.
And they're given, I think, like you get in restaurants.
You know, when you're younger.
What?
So kind of a beeper?
Yes, a beeper.
And so if they need them, they can be the mother.
And her father was a case maybe.
These days.
And I think that's quite innovative.
I didn't know about that.
Yes, it's quite a nice project.
Sure.
They have a loop.
They've done some interesting things with the plumbing because, of course,
they needed to toilet.
And it's a little really nice little part of party.
And so they didn't put in actual plumbing.
But I think it's very well designed.
And they have students in there that are learning child care.
Oh, nice.
I think it's just a great project.
I'll have to check that out.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Well, and you're such a beaver fan.
Oh, yes, I'm a beaver.
That should definitely be in there, too, I think.
Well, you know, since I've lived in Corvallus all my life,
there's no, you know, I had three out of my four children go through Oregon state.
So where, and my husband was a graduate of Oregon state.
And I've worked for the college through the extension service.
And, you know, we've just been involved in the university all our lives.
Yeah.
And of course, my father worked at the university.
And, you know, you're just kind of all, that's where your life is being.
That's right. Yeah.
But I love the fact that you still go to the football games.
Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Oh, that football game, Saturday night was something.
It's like they're doing so well this year.
He was just so proud.
But all the officiating was, was it just terrible?
And even Mike Riley, who calls the games for the radio.
He said it was the worst officiating he'd ever seen in his life.
That's a statement.
Yes.
And the paper, I think Riley asked him to downplay it probably.
But he's a very low-key guy.
But boy was he upset with the officiating.
He called one of the players.
You know, an ask him to read through it.
Really?
And they didn't change it.
So, yeah, it was a feisty game.
Good. Good.
And you still go to those with your family?
Yes.
In fact, I did go with my daughter in son-in-law this time.
I always sometimes I use tickets for guests.
I like to entertain that way.
Because I have the tickets.
I might as well use them for something.
That's right.
Your support of the sports angle of the OSU in general.
It seems like that's a particular emphasis for you.
Yes.
And I really like basketball better.
I go to all the basketball games.
You're not doing very well on basketball this year.
But of course, when Ralph Miller was there,
why it was just what you're full.
Well, that's good.
So, are there any other projects that you think you'd like to talk about in here
or things that you're particularly proud of?
Well, I guess I'm particularly proud of my kids.
Well, that's it.
I would love to get back to that because we sort of talked about their younger life
when we were here a couple of weeks ago.
But I'd like to hear about them today and what you,
what's your most proud of each of them.
Well, Kenzy oldest.
And he lives in Southern California.
And he has two sons.
And the grandchildren are doing most,
most welcome there.
The Derek is his oldest son.
And he's married to Mindy.
And they have three children now.
And they're, she's a,
I don't think all that school.
Montessori school teacher and has a school in their home.
And Derek is very handy.
And he's made a doll house and he's made slides and he's made.
They have half their yard for the school and half the yard for their own private.
And the kids know when they come that they don't go on that side of the yard.
But they just do a whale of a job.
They're, they're growing up to be such fine young people.
It's wonderful.
And I'm very proud of them.
And my Ken lives in a,
I don't know what Ken does.
And he's on the,
the California Water Board.
He does something about that.
He's also done something with hazardous waste.
He's been on committees about that.
Is he an engineer?
No, he really isn't.
He's a, he was a business major.
He started out as being a forest major.
But he, every time he went to class, he,
a field trip, he had poison open.
So he had to give that up.
And so he was a business major.
And then he got his MBA.
And something.
But he's, he's dabbled in a lot of things.
And he lives in on 10 acres in an avocado grove.
And raises those great big avocado.
Oh, yes.
That's a great.
That's a good.
And just then.
And his wife is a psychologist.
And the children all call her the shrink.
That's great.
And their second son.
And the second one was in the military.
What's his name?
Danny.
And he was in the military for about 10 years.
I think in Mary to really nice girl.
And they have two children.
And he's out of the military now.
And taking a lot of mechanics.
And well, I guess you'd say mechanics,
because I think it's a combination of auto and airplane.
A lot of mechanics.
He likes to work with his hands.
So he does that.
Then Craig's the next boy.
And he lives in Bend.
And he does.
Well, I don't know what Craig does.
He runs some sort of a business called bad checks.
And he takes checks that are bouncing.
And does something with him.
And I've never been able to figure out what he does.
But anyway, he does that.
And then he's a hunter and a fisherman.
And seems to earn enough money to play quite a bit.
And he also has some friends who are quite wealthy.
And he goes with them.
Because Craig's a fun guy.
And he has children as well.
Yes, he has two.
And one is going to school here at LBCC.
And is going to be.
She's studying to be a.
Well, I don't know what she's studying to be.
Anyway, she's going to school.
That's her name.
Tracy.
And then McKinsey goes to.
Scared, which is Savannah College of Art and Design in Savannah, Georgia.
And she's studying jewelry.
And she apparently is very good because.
She just designed some piece that the teacher is taking to Hong Kong to show.
And some group there over there.
Wow.
I guess it's quite a thing in her body.
She has been thinking that she would like to buy a Savannah house.
You know, an antique house of some sort.
And have a store below.
A jewelry store below.
And have a book above.
So she's got her life all figured out.
Then there's Kathy, who lives in Portland, K-A-T-H-Y.
And she's married to me, Clifford.
And which is kind of interesting.
Because you know, we have a man over here who was Clifford.
Mead.
Thank you.
And the, you know, a line is falling.
And it's straight to the earthy.
Mead.
So anyway, you got to be careful with which way you got.
And he was a man who, man.
He called it.
I don't think all that business.
Anyway, it was starring hospital records.
And he built that up to a very big business.
And then all of a sudden Iron Mountain came in.
And they were an international company.
And they bought him out.
So he does some other things now.
Did they have children?
Yes, they have three.
And it's the oldest one is brand.
And he goes to school at, oh, I can't tell you.
It's, it's, it's one of the California schools.
It's, it's San Diego.
It's the Catholic school.
That's in San Diego up on the hill.
I'm going to bed up.
Very petite.
There's prestigious school.
But I, I never know whether it's the university.
No, I don't think it's got university.
And because it's a private, it's a Catholic school.
They are Catholic.
But he wanted to go to some place where he could wear flip-flops and shorts.
He found it.
So he's, and he's, I'm going to graduate this year.
And he thinks he's going to go to law school.
Great.
And then Colin is the high school senior.
I don't know what I'm going to do about.
Graduation this year.
We've got all these kids graduating.
I'm a Kinsey of graduate from SCAD.
Um, we're going to graduate from California.
Colin's going to graduate from Lincoln High School.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
How do you know?
I always.
You don't have to map it out with that.
What's the calendar?
Um, so, and that's Colin.
And he goes to Lincoln High School.
What is interesting, you know?
Um, well, the poor kid.
He's had health problems.
And he wants to be an athlete.
But he, he, just had these tonsils out.
And it was a real brutal operation.
He was in the hospital for two or three days.
Was tonsils.
He and he don't hear about it.
Yeah.
But they say that when you're older and you have your tonsils out,
it's real rough.
And it was.
He just had a few days there of being miserable.
Um, so I don't know.
Uh, what Colin will, will be interested in.
Um, he's looking at schools now.
Um, and then there's no bread.
Who is, um, interested in nothing but look across.
He said bread was the oldest.
Yes.
Then Colin and then Brent.
No, Brent.
I see.
I got to Brent somehow.
Oh, who is it?
No.
The, um, oh, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Grant is what I meant.
Grant is the oldest.
Okay.
Colin and then Brent.
Brent.
Great.
Alright.
And Grant's look across.
Oh, that's his.
He leaves, sleeps, eats everything across.
And I guess he's a pretty good little player because he was chosen as one of two in the
part and district to, wow, represent the teams that play.
He's played in Philadelphia.
And this is a middle school.
Huh?
Oh, he's still in middle school.
That's amazing.
And he played in Philadelphia.
And he played in Seattle.
And he played in Southern California.
I understand that.
I think that's too much for middle school kids.
Oh, yeah.
But that's what they do these days.
Oh, yes.
It sure is.
And I guess he's pretty darn good.
So that's his passion.
And there's, didn't there's Kim.
Uh-huh.
She's the baby.
And she's married to Walt.
And she and Walt are now doing the courtyard.
You know, do you know about the courtyard?
Yeah.
And that's rebel ones.
Rebel, rebel ones.
Something like that they call it.
And they've been working really hard to get these students.
So we get it.
If fixed up so that students could live there,
who was in terrible shape.
Hmm.
And they've got 14 students living there.
And they're the nicest young people.
They have to be kind of religiously oriented.
Not any particular denomination, just.
And they're all enthusiastic about where they live.
They're spreading the word.
And Kim said, by next year they'll have a waiting list.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
So are they living here in town while they were here?
Yes.
They live out at the end of 29th Street.
Great.
Otherwise did she live in Portland before?
Yes.
Has she lived completely down here?
And yes.
Walt's been an interesting husband.
He was an FFA boy.
Uh-huh.
And he went with when he finished college.
He had six screen houses and ran a nursery.
Hmm.
Took up to Carter culture in in college.
But he's gone through.
Oh, he worked for a rubber company.
And he worked for.
Uh, he's always landed on his feet with a very good job.
Hmm.
And, um, but now they're deciding that they'll do this.
So.
Who knows what they're doing.
Uh-huh.
And she was a teacher.
Kim?
Yes, uh-huh.
You know, she was trained as a teacher.
She's not doing that anymore.
No.
She's working with Walt.
I'm with Rev.
Once.
Okay.
She was substituting when they lived in Portland.
Uh-huh.
Great.
And they have twin daughters.
Uh-huh.
Jennifer and Kristen.
Hmm.
And, um.
Kristen is, um.
Uh.
She graduated from.
See how specific.
Hmm.
And, um, in, um, business.
And has a job in Portland with a computer company that she, um, hates her job.
That's good money.
And Jennifer has, um, graduated in home economics.
We'll help the human science.
Uh-huh.
And, uh, has a job in Portland that she just loves.
But doesn't make much money.
Uh-huh.
It's so often it has to trade off.
But it's fun that she's continuing on in the home economics field.
Well, no.
She, she manages, um, an office for some brokers.
Oh, she does.
She has their degree, but she doesn't use it.
No.
Oh.
Well, it's still that she has the same interest that you did in home economics.
It's nice that you share that.
Well, yes.
She, she did.
And she worked a lot in kids' spirit when she was here.
Uh-huh.
And school.
She worked at kids' spirit almost all the time.
She was here.
Yeah.
So, um, it's wonderful that you can even name all these girls and children and talk about each of them individually.
Did you spend a lot of time with them when they were growing up?
Well, more so with kids, children and the rest of them because they were in Portland.
And, um, well, I spent time with, with Kathy's children when they were younger.
But, uh, I don't drive to Portland anymore.
So, I don't see them nearly as often as I used to.
Uh-huh.
But I know they stay in touch just from the fact that last time I was here one of somebody called
maybe one of your California grandchildren.
Oh, golden.
Oh, yeah.
They all call.
We would wonder.
We think cell phones are just great.
That's good.
Yeah.
Did, um, what were some of the things that you did with them when you could get, get to spend
time with them?
Well, we, we shopped a lot.
And, uh, they, they love to shop with grandma because, you know, who's by semester.
Yeah.
Like, is there the same?
And, um, um, but we, we did a lot of things together.
We had a lot of picnics together.
Mm-hmm.
Um.
Did you ever share your cooking and sewing in those kind of skills with them?
Well, not much, maybe, maybe making sugar cookies.
They all like my sugar cookies.
And, uh, this holiday, I'm taking the rolls and the sugar cookies for my part of the
Thanksgiving dinner.
Wow.
That's good.
And last night, Craig said, I said something about boy.
It would take me a long time to make rolls.
I said, I just thought as fast as I used to be.
And he said, well, don't worry about the rolls.
Just bring the sugar cookies.
Kind of priorities, that's a good thing.
That's kind of a thing that I'm noted for.
That's good.
Uh, did you have that experience of, um, just finding out how much fun it was to be a grand
parent with, you know, enjoying your time with them and not having quite as much of the work
as you do when you're a parent?
Well, I loved it when Kim had her twins because she lived in Lebanon at that time.
Uh-huh.
And, uh, and Walt was still doing the nursery.
Mm-hmm.
And, um, so when Walt, when she and Walt were married, uh, she had another year
to school.
She was married when she was a junior and, and Walt was a senior.
Mm-hmm.
And, um, but her daddy had said, I don't mind you getting married, but he said, you're
going to finish school.
Mm-hmm.
Well, of course, what happened was that she got pregnant.
Uh-huh.
And then they found out they were having twins.
And, of course, in the meantime, he died.
And so, anyway, I said, you know you promised your daddy that, if you got married
and she said, I know.
So, anyway, um, they, I said, my advice to you is to get busy and she only had her
doing teaching to do.
Mm-hmm.
And I said, you need to do that before your kids get mobile.
I said, it's a lot easier to take care of them when they're in the, in the, in, not
wandering around.
And Walt was home during the day because he was running the nursery.
So, if there was an emergency, he was there.
Yeah.
So, that worked out well.
So, anyway, Kim was able to get a, um, student teaching situation in Lebanon.
Mm-hmm.
So, uh, she wasn't far away.
And so, she finished up and got her degree while she was doing that.
Mm-hmm.
And then, um, then, uh, but I was over there a lot, taking care of the youngsters.
And they'd have, um, full-time help, but, um, it was, um, you know, I, I like to go over there
and help feed the kids.
I can imagine.
She was a great mother.
She, uh, twins didn't bother Canada.
She, I can still see her sitting on the dad important one.
Baby would be laying over there.
And she'd be feeding this one and that one would be yelling.
Uh-huh.
She'd pat him on the back and say, no, it's your turn.
She was a wonderful mother.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Good.
So, with that last time when I was here, you got that phone call.
You were going to be sending down, um, one of your boys jackets to one of your great grandkids.
Yes.
And I did that.
And he's absolutely ecstatic.
That is so sweet.
Yeah.
So, this one, uh, was a red, flannel, well, boy scout jacket.
I don't know that you know, but that's quite a deal when they get back.
Yeah.
And then they, they put all their patches on.
Mm-hmm.
And so, this one was all covered in patches.
And so, I said, to Ken, my son, I said, what do you think I ought to do with these patches?
And he said, well, I take him off because he needs to earn his own patches.
Yeah.
So he, uh, so anyway, I'm got them all in a little Ziploc bag.
And I'm taking him over to Craig, who earned the patches.
And then I sent the coat to the cleaners.
And it's been sent down to, yeah, to, um, what's he saying?
And those guys down.
Uh, let's see.
I didn't get the name of the great grandchildren, I guess.
Derek or Danny's kids, huh?
Yeah.
Well, it's Derek's kids.
Um, well, anyway, whoever's getting it.
And, um, and he said, so Ken called me and he said, boy, is he one happy boy?
Oh.
He said he was just crazy about.
And you know, it looked brand new and it got back from the cleaners.
It was just great.
That's fine.
It kind of fluffed up all of those sewing that would have been on it.
Uh-huh.
We're down just really well.
It's good.
Good.
Why are there other things that you have that you saved from when you were a little girl
that you would have been able to pass on to your grandchildren that they've enjoyed?
Well, I don't really think of anything off hand.
Um, uh, oh, no, I don't.
The only thing that I have saved really of Kathy's is that she made a dress with beautiful
satin stitch.
And I could show that to you.
It, uh, and it, um, I think it's a real special little dress.
And it's been hanging back there for 20 years just because I enjoy looking at it.
Uh-huh.
Do you want to see it?
I'd love to.
Well, let's wait till we're done.
Unless you need to get up and stretch a little bit.
No, no.
I'm just stretching my legs out.
We're doing here for time.
Two, three.
Should we plan to stop at three again?
It's two.
It's 20 minutes to three now.
I have to be fine.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
And then we're just about three or four.
We are.
I think this will be our last form.
We'll get together.
Uh-huh.
I want to keep open the possibility of giving you a call if while I'm putting this together.
Yes.
Absolutely.
I understand.
So I had some sort of general questions that are more or less reflections on life and
and could tell me if you're comfortable answering these kinds of things.
But I like to have a little bit of people's philosophy in these books too.
Because I feel like what you're leaving in with this book is a statement of your legacy.
There's so much about your death legacy out there.
And I think, well, Gene has a legacy of her on this.
She's leaving here.
Do you have a sense of what you want your legacy to be, what you think your children
and your community should remember about you?
I hope those are hard things to answer.
I should have given you these questions in advance.
Yeah.
Because I just hope that people remember that I try to live by the golden rule.
I guess it's my philosophy.
I'd like to have people treat me like I want to be treated and I want to treat them.
And I've always kind of lived by that, hopefully by that philosophy that I don't know
really what else to say about that is I want to feel like I'm all I'm on this earth
that I'm contributing something to society.
And I guess that that's why I like to get out and do things and I don't want to just set.
Right.
Do you stay active?
We haven't talked about knitting either, Henry.
I'd like to hear more of that.
That's one of my hobbies.
You've shown me, and you actually told me that you got started on that back when you were in high school
when you were waiting for your dad to pick you up.
Right.
This piece is coming along nicely, though, are you getting close to the end of it?
Yeah, so I'm getting like close to the end of it.
Just love the colors that you chose for that.
This is for Colin.
Uh-huh.
And I've been busy.
I've been busy.
The end there.
Oh, John.
I'm losing something.
Not quite.
I'm hit an African for each one of the children.
Oh, yeah.
Most of them, at least the ones that have asked for it.
Uh-huh.
And so he's a big boy and so.
He wanted something heavy and his mother wanted something that he wouldn't put his toes through.
They'd play.
Uh-huh.
And so that's for that.
But this one is.
And you know, we might take a picture of that one time.
Because I'm most proud of this African.
Can I?
It's the one that I did.
Oh, I was waiting for him when he was a football player.
Uh-huh.
I mean, most of this under a street light.
Waiting in your car?
Well, he was impressed.
Yeah.
It's gorgeous.
And I'm a variety of stitches in this one.
So I'm really pleased with this one.
Now how did you end up with that?
If you needed it for him.
Oh, I didn't need it for him.
Oh, just.
Why?
Oh, he was.
He was playing.
Oh, I did it for myself.
It's just gorgeous.
Well, I don't want to sample her, isn't it?
With all the.
Yes, it is.
You're trying to stitching it.
But I've never, I don't know how many of these.
I knit one for Uncle Norm.
That was my husband's brother.
Uh-huh.
And he, I had a real hard time.
He, they were when he was getting older.
He, they just kind of chopped him in pieces.
He, he lost a leg.
Uh-huh.
And, you know, an arm.
Do you have diabetes?
No.
I don't know what he had.
So long time ago when I forgot what he had.
But anyway, he, um, he needed to blank it to keep warm.
He didn't have very good circulation.
So I did him one and I didn't.
I don't know how many afters I did.
I might take a picture of that one too before I leave here.
Well, that would, I'd love to have a picture of that to put in the book as well.
Well, I think I'm real proud of this.
Wow, that's really gorgeous.
I think it's probably the fanciest one that I've got.
Uh-huh.
And I do needle point.
That's a needle point.
One that I did.
Which one?
That one.
The pillow?
Mm-hmm.
Beautiful.
I love the colors.
I have a couple of the beach that I've done in shells.
Uh-huh.
That sort of thing.
Ooh.
Can I have good eyes for that project?
Yeah.
Tiny little stitches.
I did all of it except the border and I got to the point where I just couldn't do those fine stitches.
Uh-huh.
It was pink on the background too and I couldn't see where I'd been and where I was going.
Yeah.
So we'll finish it up for you.
But Kathy, she does.
Uh-huh.
She does beautiful needle point.
She's-my-she has inherited more of my clothing and textiles.
Uh-huh.
A bill of tea.
Yeah.
And anybody else?
Uh-huh.
Can it doesn't like to do that much?
So, um...
You've been a single woman for quite a long time.
Uh-huh.
I'm sure that has its challenges, but are there parts of that that have been good for you
that have helped you to grow?
As a...
Well, I think, um...
Kermin and I never got to travel very much.
Uh-huh.
We did have that one lovely trip to Japan.
But I think we talked about and how we happened to go to Japan and so forth.
Uh-huh.
When, uh, this Uncle Norm died, my sister-in-law.
And I traveled quite a bit.
We probably went on five or six lovely trips.
And we traveled in Europe a lot.
Um, because, uh, my husband never wanted to go to Europe.
There was something about the World War II that he just didn't want to go to Europe.
Um, but, um, but we did go, um, a lot to other parts of the world.
But anyway, um, Marie and I traveled quite a bit together.
And, um, I always enjoyed that.
And then, um, then when, uh, my brother died, well, I met my sister and I traveled quite
a bit together.
So, um, I really enjoyed all of that very much.
So it kind of freed you up to have, uh, that kind of experience with other people.
Right.
And I had enough income then to support some travel.
So it worked out well.
Yeah.
Um, when you're, when you're, you're traveling, you're sort of seeing the world.
And, uh, seeing how other, other people live, are there, are there parts of that whole
Traveling thing that really appealed to you?
Well, of course, Hawaii is my favorite place.
Yeah.
Because it's, uh, clean.
They speak English.
And money's the same.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
It's easy.
And, uh, of course, the weather's always good.
And I, I don't remember who didn't be talk about Betty and I owning a condominium over there.
No.
Although I saw that somewhere else, and I meant to ask you about that.
So you have a condominium together?
We did.
Uh-huh.
Well, you don't have it anymore.
No.
Well, of course, she's gone.
She's gone for several years.
But, um, we were, um, she had Alzheimer's.
And, uh, when we decided that we wanted to do this condominium together, we said that we were just going to let the family use it.
Mm-hmm.
Well, all of a sudden, I began to hear people were thinking me for going to hear stay in my condominium.
Uh-huh.
Well, I thought that she was being a little bit presumptuous.
But it turned out that she, she really, you know, had not remembered that we had this understand.
Yeah.
And, uh, so anyway, I said that, uh, I didn't give her any reason why, but I just said that I thought that,
that maybe I wasn't going to be interested in having the condominium anymore.
And she said, well, she'd buy me out.
So it was all very admirable, everything.
And then I realized a few years later that she just really wasn't herself.
Mm-hmm.
So it was okay.
Yeah.
And my nephews just couldn't be nicer to me.
They're just wonderful boys.
That's great.
So when you were in Hawaii, did you do that?
You said, uh, Kermit was a scuba diver early on.
Were you a scuba diver as well?
Yes.
He taught me how to scuba diver.
And, uh, we always went snorkeling.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, and I would, I was, it is, um,
So, um, I wasn't, um, comfortable going by myself too much.
And so he would always take my hand and me go out together,
and look and then he'd say,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
But Betty and I did a lot of that too because she liked to, to snarkle.
Huh.
So when we were, when we had our condominium,
we would, uh, co-snarling almost everyday.
Oh, that sounds wonderful.
How long did you have it together?
About three years.
Uh-huh.
That's great.
Good.
And I think most of the kids had it once or twice.
their twice. They all went over once or twice. They were at the age where they didn't have
a lot of extra money for the fair over and along the staying and so they could manage it
every once in a while but not too often. Sounds like a real treat. And you had taken them
over quite a bit when they were younger. Yes, we had always gone over on spring break.
That's a good thing. Good. You know, one thing we didn't talk about. I know that
Kermit was involved in the church and you've always been involved with the church as well.
Are you, do you consider yourself a spiritual person or? Well, I think I am. I'm more
of, um, I think I'm not a, I don't talk about religion too much. My, my daughter and
son-in-law came in water. Very religious and they, they talk about it all the time and they
pray before heels and that sort of thing. I'm more of a one who keeps their religion kind of to
themselves. And my husband, I think I've got a lot of his feelings in me because he always said that
if he dealt with some business man who broadcast his religion and had
visible things on his desk that portrayed his religion. It just raised a red flag with him because he
said, I know too many men who go to church every Sunday and just go back by two during the week.
And I think I've inherited a lot of that feeling. I try to live by the golden rule, as I say.
All right. Well, we have just about five more minutes and I think I can get limit us to maybe three
questions. Okay. At that time, the other sort of big picture issue I wanted to ask you about
whether they were any sort of social or political issues that that have been important to you
as you've come through your life or anything that have been. Well, I, I am a firm believer that
you should, what is it's about the babies and I think it should be between your husband and your
doctor and yourself. And I'm really myth that people can't see that that it's none of the
government's business. It's a prochoice. Yeah, I'm sure I am. And have you ever been active in any
of the kind of causes or just a personally healthy? I'm not in a cause person. That's good. You've
been active in causes sort of in the back of your influence. Yeah, I think. And I guess the other thing
is that in in church too that I feel that if you want to be a, what are you when you're
lesbian, I guess. You know, the congregational churches of big on people being lesbian
and I had to give up the congressional church even though with the my background is in the
congregational church, but it's also in the Presbyterian church, but but I'm a Presbyterian now because
I could, they, they hired a lady. I don't know the, remember this, but probably 10 maybe 15 years ago.
A lady came and was part of the Presbyterian church and I think she was the Sunday school teacher
that they, they hired the young people. And she thought that lesbians were just the best thing
that ever happened to anybody. And she would have, when she first came, there was a picture of
her in the paper almost every week about what she believed in and I thought I am just sick of that.
And so I, the minister came to see me and I said, do you advertise what goes on in your bedroom?
Well, no, and I said, well, I don't know why lesbians have to advertise that they're
that persuasion. And so I said, I'm, I'm just not going to support the church until you change
your rules. And so that's moved on from there now. Yeah, and it was more a matter of the,
how public she was being about. Yes, yes. I don't care, the whole neck teachers over here have
always lived together. But they haven't advertised what, and a lot of them were just doing it
because they needed friendship, you know, and there's nothing wrong with that. But to advertise,
you know how you feel about your personal, it just calls me. Yeah, that's, and I don't mind if you
print that. All right, that's why it's an important stance, I think. I think that's good.
If you had to pinpoint what's your, what's your grateful for in this life,
you've talked so much about your family and things like that. Are there particular things that you
think about how grateful you are to have had in your life? Yes, I think I'm grateful for the fact
that I've had a good education, and that I have been able to use it in many different ways
and that I've been able to contribute to society. Yes, and that I've been able to
to earn enough money to live comfortably. And to share what you have. Yes,
are there, is there anything that feels sort of unfinished about your life at this point? Are there
things that you still have left to do or that you feel like you would like to do better?
Well, no, I don't really think there's any unfinished business. Well, I don't know that I
had any great broad plans to do anything at kind of all just sort of evolved. That's life.
Oh, I don't think I have any grand notions of what I could accomplish or anything.
It was just that when the opportunity came and I could see that I could help a little bit,
but I took advantage of that, but it wasn't anything pre-meditated. Do you have any advice
I'm thinking about your grandchildren, great grandchildren reading this and wondering if
there is anything that you would suggest to them in terms of kind of an overall way to live your life.
Well, I think the main thing is that you need to be fair and you need to be honest
and you need to take advantage of opportunities that are present in themselves.
And I just think that it's important that you be happy.